The stadiums are a very essential part of the FIFA World Cup...
...and definitely are not only the heart and soul of an event like the World Cup...
...but also an important part of a legacy of this event...
...in terms of the infrastructure left in the host country.
That's why it's an essential part...
...and a very important element of our sustainability strategy.
With this, our responsibility and the responsibility of the local organizing committee...
...to take measures, in order to, as much as possible...
...increase the positive impact that the World Cup has...
...and reduce the negative impact that it has on both society and the environment.
Most of the stadiums underwent that certification...
...and that is the basis upon which we build on...
...with the training for the stadium operators in terms of sustainability.
Beyond the World Cup, it's not for the World Cup, but also to provide lessons to them,...
...and let it to be a legacy to our country to manage this in a good way.